13.8 billion years ago is the origin of
our universe 3.8 billion years ago is
the origin of life here on our little
planet the one we call Earth
let's say 200 000 years ago is the
appearance of early Homo sapiens so let
me ask you this question how rare are
these events in the vastness of space
and time or put it in a more fun way how
many intelligent aliens civilizations do
you think are out there in this universe
us being one of them I suppose there
should be some statistically but we
don't have any evidence but I do think
that you know intelligence in any way
it's a bit overvalued we are the most
intelligent entities on this planet and
look what you're doing
so intelligence also tends to be
self-destructive which implies that if
there are or were intelligent life forms
elsewhere maybe they don't survive for
long do you think there's a tension
between happiness and intelligence
absolutely intelligence is definitely
not something that is directed towards
amplifying happiness I I would also
emphasize the huge huge difference
between intelligence and Consciousness
which many people certainly in the tech
industry and in the AI industry tend to
miss
intelligence is simply the ability to
solve problems
to attain goals
and you know to to win a chess to uh win
a struggle for survival to win a war to
drive a car uh to diagnose the disease
this is intelligence
Consciousness is the ability to feel
things like pain and pleasure and love
and hate in humans and other animals
intelligence and Consciousness go
together they go hand in hand which is
why we confuse them we solve problems we
attain goals by having feelings
but other types of intelligence
certainly in computers computers are
already highly intelligent and as far as
we know they have zero Consciousness
when a computer beats you at chess or go
or whatever it doesn't feel happy if it
loses it doesn't feel sad
and uh there could be also other highly
intelligent
entities out there in the universe that
have zero Consciousness and I think that
Consciousness is far more important and
valuable than intelligence can you
stream on the case that Consciousness
and intelligence
are intricately connected so not just in
humans but anywhere else they had they
have to go hand in hand is it possible
for you to imagine such a universe
it it could be but we don't know yet
again we have examples certainly we know
of examples of high intelligence without
Consciousness computers are one example
um as far as we know
plants are not conscious
yet they are intelligent they can solve
problems they can attain goals in very
sophisticated ways
so um
the other way around to have
Consciousness without any intelligence
this is probably impossible but to
having intelligence without
Consciousness yes that's possible a
bigger question is whether any of that
is tied to organic biochemistry we know
on this planet only about carbon-based
life forms whether you're an amoeba a
dinosaur a tree a human being you're
based on organic biochemistry
um is there an essential connection
between organic biochemistry and
Consciousness do all conscious entities
everywhere in the universe or in the
future on planet Earth have to be based
on carbon is there something so special
about carbon as an element that an
entity based on Silicon will never be
conscious
I don't know maybe
but again this is a key question about
computer and computer consciousness
that can computers eventually become
conscious even though they are not
organic the jury is still out on that I
don't know I mean that we have to take
both options into account well a big
part of that
is do you think we humans would be able
to detect other intelligent beings other
conscious beings another way to ask that
is it possible that the aliens are
already here and we don't see them
meaning are we
very human-centric in our understanding
of one the definition of life to the
definition of intelligence and three the
definition of consciousness
the aliens are here they are just not
from outer space AI which is usually
stands for artificial intelligence I
think it stands for alien intelligence
because AI is an alien type of
intelligence it solves problems attains
goals in a very very different way in an
alien way from human beings and I'm not
implying that AI Came From Outer Space
it came from Silicon Valley but it is
alien to us if there are alien
intelligent or conscious entities that
came from outer space already here and
I've I've not seen every any evidence
for it it's not impossible but you know
in science evidence is everything well I
mean I guess instructive there's uh just
having the humility to look around to
think about living beings that operate
at a different time scale a different
spatial scale and I think that's all
useful when starting to analyze
artificial intelligence
it's
possible that even the language models
the larger language models we have today
are already conscious I I highly doubt
it but I think
a question of social norms because we
cannot prove Consciousness in anybody
except ourselves we know that we are
conscious because we are feeling it we
have direct access to our subjective
Consciousness we have we cannot have any
proof that any other entity in the world
any other human being or parents our
best friends we don't have proof of
their conscious you know this is this
has been known for thousands of years
this is the card this is Buddha this is
Plato we we don't we can't have this
sort of proof what we do have is Social
conventions
a social convention that all human
beings are conscious it's also applies
to animals most people who have pets are
firmly believe that their patch pets are
conscious but a lot of people still
refuse to acknowledge that about cows or
pigs now pigs are far more intelligent
than dogs and cats you know according to
many measures yet when you go to the
supermarket and and buy a a piece of
Frozen pigment you don't think about it
as a conscious entity why do you think
of your dog as conscious but not of the
of the bacon that you buy because you
build a relationship with the dog and
you don't have a relationship with the
bacon Now relationships they are they
don't constitute a logical proof for
Consciousness there are a social tests
that the Turing test is a social test
it's not a logical proof now if you
establish a a mutual relationship with
an entity
when you are invested in it emotionally
you're almost compelled to feel that the
other side is also conscious
and when it comes down to Ai and
computers I think and I don't think that
at the present moment computers are
conscious but people are already forming
intimate relationships with AIS and are
therefore
almost irresists it's almost
irresistible they are compelled to to
increasingly feel that these are
conscious entities
and I think we are quite close to the
point when the legal system will have to
take this into account
that even though I don't think computers
have Consciousness I think we are close
to the point the legal system will start
treating them as conscious entities
because of this social convention
what to you is uh social convention
just a funny little side effect a little
artifact or is it fundamental to what
Consciousness is because if it is
fundamental then it seems like AI is
very good at forming these kinds of deep
relationships with humans yeah and
therefore you'll be able to be a nice
Catalyst for
uh integrating itself into these social
conventions of ours
it was built to accomplish that yeah we
are design again you know all these
arguments between a a a natural
selection and uh creationism intelligent
design
as far as the past go all entities
evolved by natural selection the funny
thing is but when you look at the future
more and more entities will come out of
intelligent design not of some God above
the clouds but of our intelligent design
and the intelligent design of our clouds
of our Computing clouds they will Design
more and more entities and this is what
is happening with AI it is designed
to be very good at forming intimate
relationships with humans
and uh um in many ways it's already
doing it almost better than human beings
in some situations you know when two
people talk with one another one of the
things that kind of uh um makes the
conversation more difficult is our own
emotions
you're saying something and I'm not
really listening to you because there is
something I want to say and I'm just
waiting until you finish I I can put in
a word or I'm so obsessed with my anger
or irritation or whatever that I don't
pay attention to what you're feeling
this is one of the biggest obstacles in
human relationships and computers don't
have this problem because they don't
have any emotions of their own so you
know when a computer is talking to you
it can be the most it can focus a
hundred percent of its attention is on
your what you're saying and what you're
feeling because it has no feelings of
its own and paradoxically this means
that computers can fool people
into feeling that uh oh there is a
conscious entity on the other side an
empathic entity on the other side
because the one thing everybody wants
almost more than anything in the world
is for somebody to listen to me somebody
to focus all their attention on me like
I want it for my spouse for my husband
from my mother for my friends for my
politicians listen to me listen to what
I feel and they often don't and now you
have this entity which a hundred percent
of its attention is just on what what I
feel and this is a huge huge Temptation
and I think also a huge huge Danger
well the interesting Catch-22 there is
you said somebody to listen to us yes we
want somebody to listen to us but for us
to respect that somebody hmm
they sometimes have to also not listen
it's like
um they kind of have to be an
sometimes they have to have moods
sometimes they have to have like
self-importance and confidence and and
uh we should have a little bit of fear
that they can walk away at any moment
there should be a little bit of that
tension so it's like absolutely
I mean the thing is
inattention is good for a conversation
because then you feel challenged oh you
need to grab this person's attention you
can program the AI to have 17 exactly 17
in attention not one percentage more or
less or it can by trial and error
discover what is the the ideal
percentage again you you can create over
the last 10 years we have creating
machines for grabbing people's attention
this is what has been happening on
social media now we are designing
machines for grabbing human intimacy
which in many ways it's much much more
dangerous and scary already the machines
for grabbing attention we've seen how
much social and political damage they
could do by in in when you buy kind of
distorting the public conversation
machines that are superhuman in their
abilities to create Intimate
Relationships this is like psychological
and social weapons of mass destruction
if we don't
regulate it if we don't train ourselves
to deal with it it could destroy the
foundations of human society well one of
the possible trajectories is those same
algorithms would become personalized and
instead of manipulating us at scale
there would be assistance that guide us
to help us grow to help us understand
the world better I mean just even
interactions with um
with large language models now if you
ask them questions
it doesn't have that stressful drama the
tension that you have from other sources
of information it has a pretty balanced
perspective that it provides so it just
feels like that's uh the potential is
there to have a really nice
friend who's like an encyclopedia that
just tells you all the different
perspectives even on controversial
issues the most controversial issues to
say these are the different theories
these are
um the not widely accepted conspiracy
theories but that here's the kind of
backing for those conspiracies it just
lays it all out and with a calm language
without the TR without the words that
kind of
um presume there's some kind of
manipulation going on under Underneath
It All it's it's quite refreshing of
course those are the early days and you
know people can step in and start to
censor to manipulate those algorithms to
start to input some of the human biases
in there as opposed to the what's
currently happening is kind of
the internet is input
uh compress it and have a nice little
output that uh gives an overview of the
different issues so I mean there's a lot
of promise there also right absolutely I
mean if there was no promise promise
there was no problem you know if this
technology could not accomplish anything
good nobody would develop it now
obviously it has tremendous positive
potential in things like what you just
described in you know better medicine
better Healthcare better education so
many promises and but this is also why
it's so dangerous because uh the the
drive to develop it faster and faster is
there and it has some dangerous
potential also and we shouldn't ignore
it again I'm not advocating Banning it
uh just to be you know careful about how
we not not so much develop it but most
importantly how we deploy it into the
public sphere this is the key question
and you know you look back at history
and one of the things we we know from
history humans are not good with new
technologies I hear many people now say
you know AI it's uh we've been here
before we had the radio we had the
printing press we had the Industrial
Revolution every time there is a big new
technology people are afraid and it will
take jobs and build up the Bad actors
and in the end it's okay
and as a historian my tendency is yes in
the end it's okay but in the end there
is a learning curve there is a kind of a
lot of failed experiments on the way to
to learning how to use the new
technology and these failed experiments
could cause the lives of hundreds of
millions of people if you think about
the last really big revolution the
Industrial Revolution yes in the end we
learned how to use the powers of
Industry electricity radio trains
whatever to build better human societies
but on the way
we had all these experiments like
European imperialism which was driven by
the Industrial Revolution it was a
question how do you build an industrial
society oh you build an Empire and you
take you you control all the resources
the raw materials the markets and then
you had communism another big experiment
on how to build an industrial society
and you had Fascism and Nazism which
were essentially an experiment in how to
build an industrial society including
even how do you exterminate minorities
using the powers of of industry and we
had all these failed experiments on the
way and if we now have the same type of
failed experiments with the Technologies
of the 21st century with AI with
bioengineering it could cost the lives
of again hundreds of millions of people
and maybe destroyed the species
so um as a historian when people talk
about the examples from history from
from new technologies I'm not so
optimistic we need to to to think about
the failed experiment which accompanied
every major new technology
so this intelligence thing like you were
saying is a double-edged sword is that
every
new thing it helps us create it can uh
both save us and destroy us and it's
unclear each time which will happen and
that's maybe why we don't see any aliens
um yeah I mean I think each time he does
both things each time he does both good
things and bad things and the more
powerful the technology the greater both
the positive and the negative outcomes
now we are here
because we are the descendants of the
survivors of the surviving cultures the
surviving uh civilizations so when we
look back we say in the end everything
was okay hey we are here
but the people for whom it wasn't okay
they are just not here